bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
ce soir en direct sur arte france c'est
la question qui revient ces dernières
heures la situation à taïwan peut-elle
déclencher une guerre on évoque même une
troisième guerre mondiale est ce que la
question vous semble pertinente jean
vincent brisset
les états unis et pékin mais la première
chose c'est que d'abord la paix qu un
son rock taiwan
taiwan et multiplie les provocations et
ça c'est la première chose ensuite
ont-ils réagi
sur les communautés sont pas des lois
c'est effectivement une certaine
ambiguïté mais sont des textes qui
oblige plus ou moins déterminé à
garantir les bailleurs
et 4 aujourd'hui dans une optique
d'interventions militaires à taiwan
douglas yates le président chinois xi
jinping réaffirmé récemment sa volonté
de parvenir à une réunification
pacifique
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire ses propos
sophie ces terrifiantes l'idée que la
chine est tellement obsédé reprendre une
petite île au mais en fait les taiwan
était mannequin mais comme une
forteresse océanique et si les bases
principales dans la lironde contre
expansion de la chine dans le mur du sud
dans la mer de chine méridionale et le
chine savez bien man on arrive à une
augmentation de prix de matières
premières c'est le moment pour la chine
et si le cours y faire exclusivement
comme l'or aussi en ukraine pendant que
les états unis d'or elle donc joe boyd
n'a essayé de montrer que les états unis
sont en fait un pronostic de défense de
taiwan mais l'alliance des états unis
est en ruine et le politique américaine
divisez politique mon et donc brian
ching politique étrangère beats qui
pratique il a trouvé dans une guerre
froide contre la chine la républicaine
et les démocrates se soudent de cette
question parce que le taiwan en plus
d'être une forteresse stratégique
partage les valeurs démocratiques avec
les états unis et peuvent représenter le
politique de l'occident dorian vous
évoqué jean-vincent brisset c'est
incursions menées par la chine dans la
zone de défense aérienne de taiwan
incursions menées depuis un an il ya
aussi le précédent hong kong est quelle
influence est-ce que ça sur la situation
actuelle
je pense que possible longuet a
convaincu les quelques taïwanais qui
voyait encore l'apport commission
chinois d'une réunification
un pays deux systèmes et est repris et
que ça ne pourrait jamais fonctionné
donc alors à près de la population tag
régime il
est
quoi paniquer qu'on pourrait penser
le seul problème c'est que à force de
multiplier les incursions il ya
forcément des réactions de l'armée de
l'air taïwanaise est nullissime
taïwanais on peut avoir un abbé rapaces
et un incident grave bien à ce moment-là
on sait pas ce qui peut se passer il ya
des forces présentes des foires pékinois
se présentait aussi des forces
américaines vont et viennent dans la
zone il ya eu dernièrement
allemandes d'être à par bateau français
ou un bateau britannique si les leaders
chinois de pékin qui sont pas forcément
très professionnel
or aucun accident grave avec des bords
il est possible que la réaction
joe biden a donc évoqué un engagement à
défendre militairement taiwan à quoi ce
qu'il fait référence de douglas y est
qu'est ce qui lie les états unis à
taïwan
on a utilisé seulement ce fraises
engagement sacré et à ça un peu
sacralisé une stratégie insulaire dans
l'optique de l'est depuis la fin de
deuxième guerre mondiale les états unis
ont accablé les bases in solaire ce
japon à okinawa sur les îlots de cory de
semer mais à antoine en le petit le pin
dans le guam et avec une énorme force et
marne les etats-unis ont essayé de gérer
la croissance de la chine et de la
russie avec une contre offre de la mer
en utilisant le pouvoir marin et donc
taiwan joueur essentiel c'est juste à
côté de la chine est là l'engagement là
nous prêtera être abandonnées sans cadre
tout le contrôle de régions et les
guerres dans la
mer de chine méridionale va se jouer
d'abord à 3 mois maintenant le ministre
de défense dit que les chinoises vont
attaquer dans les prochaines années donc
c'est le moment pour ba 2 se montre
comme kennedy pendant la crise des
missiles à cuba que les forces des etats
unis sont pas seulement dissuasive mais
utilisable deux dernières guerres les
américaines sont battus ils sont quinze
jours environnantes c'était contre la
chine et a aussi encore ils ont perdu
contre la chine et
cesser fin de partie et les états unis
coeur de la possibilité d'être
impuissante pacifique et la chine ces
montants de sept siècles donc les
batteries c'est maintenant ou jamais
les dissensions entre taiwan et la chine
sont connus de longue date pourquoi est
ce que les tensions se sont ravivées
récemment jean vincent brisset quel rôle
joue la présidente de taiwan elle défie
clairement la chine elle considère
taïwan comme un pays déjà en dépendant
des personnels avec elle est quelqu'un
qui fait partie d'un
dentiste
et comme la plupart des taiwanais elle
est pour le maintien de sa coupe au
vitam aeternam qu'est qu'une seule une
solution qui n'est pas la solution
idéale pour taiwan c'est moins
intéressant un des points mais elle
n'est pas indépendantiste je pense qu'il
faut beaucoup plus regarder ce qui se
passe à l'heure actuelle du côté de
pékin avec deux problèmes pour cet été
le premier problème pour steve dean
c'est de tester bayonne c'est ce que
j'espère que très récemment aussi le dr
voir si le bail d'honneur est aussi
odieux dans ce rapport que les épreuves
ou si comme l'a été au baba s'est
beaucoup de discours et sa cour deuxième
chose c'est bing à une opposition lui
dans son propre parti dans son propre
pays il a des vrais problèmes on refuse
de voir l soir et ce qui est quelqu'un
qui a besoin de ressouder la population
derrière lui une aventure nationaliste
c'est tout à fait ce qu'on peut
l'utiliser les régimes autoritaires
voici de ressouder la population
derrière au jeu y permet d'oublier brest
est ce que vous diriez de glace est que
le cadre de taiwan et avant toute autre
considération surtout la cristallisation
des tensions entre pékin et washington
si on rigole de loin oui mais si l'on
regarde prêts très loin ce jeu pour sa
vie il voit très clairement ce qui s'est
passé à son gant
d'abord chine parle d'une seule chine
ils vont respecter les traditions et
après lorsque sheen à two le contrôle il
commande ça a été les journalistes tués
les opposantes et volé l'argent de
rencontre donc si chine signifie l'est
avec taïwan sur la pia pure et la
vengeance d'un demi-siècle de méfiance
envers beijing donc très loin c'est un
peu comme israël dans la région il se
joue pour la vie et la chine a tout à
fait l'intention d'envahir conquérir il
fait un saut de dix bêtes en paix si fiq
de ces de ces misérables peuple si on ne
défendent pas ils vont vraiment souffert
c'est notre responsabilité morale et ses
salons gauche a créé un tout dernier mot
avec vous jean vincent briez jean
vincent brisset comment réagissent aussi
les membres de l'otan dont la montée de
ces tensions entre la chine et les états
unis quelle est la posture de l'europe
ps qu'elle prête ça être à se laisser
entraîner dans un affrontement entre ces
deux puissances
il y avait
de le drian
[Musique]
disant qu'il fallait que l'europe se
montrent en mer de chine du sud
suivie d'effet pour d'autres raisons des
pays à pays comme l'allemagne a beaucoup
changé d'avis la vie de taiwan et de et
de pékin et le fait que les allemands
aient envoyé bateaux militaires 3 et à
proximité de taiwan très récemment
montrent un changement important je
pense que petit à petit leurs rangs un
certain nombre d'européens de pays
européens et beaucoup de parlementaires
européens sont de plus en plus que coupé
par cette volonté de mainmise de pékin
sur taïwan et cette volonté de la capa
la mer de chine du sud la base 40% du
trafic mondial de marchandises par
équipe et c'est la voie
d'approvisionnement quand même pour ce
qui vient de chine et tout ce qui vient
du reste de la vie pour les européens
merci à tous les deux d'avoir participé
à cet échange ce soir jean vincent
brisset chercheur associé à l'iris et
douglas y est professeur de droit
spécialiste de sciences politiques
américaines merci et à bientôt sur rt
france